how do i get started on youtube
that's a question i came in from one of
my youtube viewers uh name is levine
holland
who wrote in to say hi everyone thank
you for your videos i'm a new financial
advisor
in toronto my hometown and would like to
get started creating good content for
youtube channel can you share how you
got started thank you
so great question for me when i'm
starting any project
related to my business if it's marketing
new project creation
services whatever it is there has to be
a founding core
reason purpose behind it so i started
doing videos
because i felt that i was a visual
learner and
i enjoyed learning from videos most of
the content that i created
was written so newsletters website
content articles that kind of stuff
and i felt that i learned better through
videos and i wanted to
do videos because i felt like it could
impact a lot more people
it suits my learning style and felt like
it could help others as well
so it wasn't i need to find a way to
market my business it wasn't i want to
be a youtube sensation
the core reason of starting this channel
was to help entrepreneurs and i felt it
was a way better
learning experience for people who are
tuning in
so you have to start with something that
you believe in and that's that's
passionate
so why are you starting this youtube
channel if it's genuine if it's going to
help people
if you're excited about it then it's
worth getting started
if it's somebody told me to start
youtube channel because it's great
marketing
you're not gonna have success with it
okay you have to start with the reason
from there any new project i start i
always start small
test it out see if it's for me see if i
can get momentum going see if i'm still
excited a couple weeks later
and then continue to invest into it i
hate spending money till i'm making
money and
with youtube there's some there's some
equipment costs
right so when i started up i just used
my regular camera
the videos sucked you can go back the
quality of the content was pretty good
but the production quality was terrible
i used my home camera no microphone
terrible lighting
had no idea what it was doing and people
still like those videos so i keep them
up on my channel even though
it's it's i feel like i should take them
down it's a little embarrassing but
people like it
and i started off small i started with
one video
and i posted it and we got some
responses and so i posted another video
and i found eventually
a way to make money doing it
because it promotes my brand promotes
what i'm talking about
and bigger companies were interested in
coming on board and sponsoring some of
them
i didn't start spending a lot of money
until i found a way to make money
and also make sure this is something i
wanted to stick with
here's the problem with a lot of
entrepreneurs we get excited about a
project we go out and we invest
a ton of our time a ton of dollars into
buying
the equipment the gear the supplies
everything we need to make this project
take off
we get into it and then it dies
you lose the excitement it's harder than
you think it was going to be it dies
and you're stuck with all this equipment
inventory supplies that now you're not
going to use
and i didn't want that to happen with my
videos i didn't want to get all excited
at the start
go out and buy a camera tripod lighting
microphone
all that gear only to then
in a couple weeks say ah you know what
this isn't for me
i'm not liking this it's not what i
thought it was gonna be and now i'm
stuck
out all this expenses so i made sure it
was for me
i got started my first camera was
uh something like my home camera wasn't
anything fancy some of the videos you'll
see are wobbly
i just put it up on my my dresser and
i filmed myself so that they weren't
great by any means
and as i learned more about it as i
started making a little bit of money off
it
then i invested into better cameras i
went through four different cameras all
through costco because it had a 90 day
return policy
where most video stores would be like 7
or 14 days
and i kept upgrading my camera because i
needed more things you know i needed to
have an external microphone jack so i
could plug in a microphone
where most cameras you know the base
models don't have it
so i kept upgrading and eventually i
stuck with what i'm using now it's a
sony camcorder it's got the external mic
i use the sony
uh microphone i have uh
the stand the tripod for the video
camera that stands on i usually
read off questions that come from
readers on my phone
and at the start i did everything myself
editing the videos producing the videos
putting up on youtube
eventually i hired somebody so now i
record all my videos put them in dropbox
and uh christina who's on my team
hey christina she's watching this video
now she's editing
uh she'll put on the intro put the music
put the effects
closing post it to my youtube channel
schedule it all that stuff so it takes
it out of my hands and freezes up my
time to do it
it started small and it built up to
become
core of what i do i'm doing 14 videos a
week now
my wednesdays are basically video days
it's wednesday
afternoon here and i'm recording my
videos it's become
core to what i do a lot of the projects
that we start up don't end up going
anywhere
but a few of them stick and become
really important and part of your
messaging part of your brain and part of
what you do
on a regular basis so it's worth
spending the time investing into it
and money when you know that this is
something that's going to be really
important to what you're going to do
most of the content that i talk about
are things that i care about
so it'll be questions that come in from
readers
just like you how did i get started on
youtube how can i you know make it
bigger
i answer questions i'll share my own
thoughts if i'm modeling a successful
entrepreneur or something that happened
to me during the week
i experiment with some raw footage of
things of me doing something or a rant
that i have
you want to make sure that each video
that you have has a message
what should people care about right it's
not just you sitting there eating
pancakes
you have something that is meaningful
that you want to share with people
that's going to touch their lives
for the few minutes that they're
spending watching your video now the
first few days you make will probably
suck you'll be nervous
it takes a lot of practice to get used
to talk in front of the camera
i had dozens of takes for each video
that came out
at the beginning now most of them is is
one shot
make the video if there's a mistake
usually just keep going through
it takes a while to get used to it to
get good at it
and and you're always going to be your
own worst critic you're going to look
back and say oh man that sucked
but you know put it up see what happens
and continue making them better
each time so that's how i got started on
youtube
and again if you're doing it for the
right reasons and you start small and
you're sharing a passionate message
then you're going to have success with
it too believe for those of you watching
you like the video please give it a
thumbs up below
makes me want to do more for you and i'd
love to hear what you got to think about
this video if you've had success on
youtube
or if you have a different question for
your business please leave it in the
comments below and i'll make a video
reply for you
thank you guys see you soon
you